We reserve some of our deepest scorn for couples
who stay together out of compromise; those
who are making a show of unanimity, but whom
we know are, deep down, not fully happy. Maybe
they’re primarily together because of the
children; maybe they’re sticking around
because they’re scared of being lonely or
maybe they’re just worried that anyone else
they found wouldn’t be much better. These
seem like disgraceful motives to be with anyone
– disgraceful on account of a background
belief that circulates powerfully through
the collective modern psyche: the idea that
anyone who puts their mind and will sufficiently
to it doesn’t have to compromise in love;
that there are pain-free, profoundly fulfilling
options available for all of us – and the
only things that could stand in the way of
discovering them would be laziness and cowardice,
flaws of character that deserve no particular
sympathy or forgiveness. Our high romantic
expectations have made us notably impatient
around, and censorious about, those who can’t
attain them. But imagine if we were to tweak
the premise of the argument a little and for
a moment probe at the notion that there really
might be a pain-free and entirely fulfilling
option available for all of us at all times.
What if our choices were, in many contexts,
in fact often rather more limited than Romanticism
proposes? Maybe there aren’t as many admirable
unattached people in our vicinity as there
might be. Maybe we lack the charm, the personality,
the career, the confidence or the looks ever
to attract the ones that do exist. Maybe time
is running out. Or maybe our children really
would take it extremely badly if we dynamited
the family for the sake of better sex and
greater cheer elsewhere. At the same time,
maybe the current situation – while clearly
a compromise – is not without its virtues.
A partner may be only half-right, quite often
maddening and properly disappointing in certain
areas, but – humblingly – still more satisfying
than being alone. Having children to bring
up together may be worth it even with a co-parent
about whom one has a long, only semi-private
list of reservations. A few cuddles and occasional
moments of cosiness may retain a small but
decisive edge over conclusive abandonment
interspersed with humiliating dates. The capacity
to compromise is not always the weakness it
is described as being. It can involve a mature,
realistic admission that there may – in
certain situations – simply be no ideal
options. And, conversely, an inability to
compromise does not always have to be the
courageous and visionary position it is held
to be by our impatient and perfectionist ideology:
it may just be a slightly rigid, proud and
cruel delusion. Mocking people who compromise
is – of course – emotionally very handy.
It localises a problem that it’s normal
to want to disavow. It pins to a few scapegoat
couples what we are all terrified of: that
a degree of sadness may just be an intrinsic,
unavoidable part of our love lives. Wiser
societies would be careful never to stigmatise
the act of compromise. It is painful enough
to have to compromise; it is even more painful
to have to hate oneself for having done so.
We should rehabilitate and occasionally honour
the ability to put up with a flawed fellow
human being, to nurse our sadness without
falling into rage or despair, to reconcile
ourselves to our damaged appearance and character
and to accept that there may be no better
way for us to live but partly in pain and
longing, given who we are and what the world
can provide. Couples who compromise may in
reality not be the enemies of love: they may
be at the vanguard of understanding what lasting
relationships truly demand.
Did you know that the school of life is actually a place?  Ten places in fact,
campuses all over the world from Melbourne to London, Taipei to Istanbul
with classes and books and much more. Please click on the link below to explore more.